With 76 lakes, the Salzkammergut, a UNESCO World Heritage Site...
...and the backdrop to the famous movie "The Sound of Music,"...
...is one of the most varied and interesting regions in Austria.
Authentic customs and traditional events are a magnet for tourists.
The area holds attractions for all seasons.
With breathtaking views of the lakes, you can forget your daily life here...
...and dive into old myths and rituals.
You stroll on the tracks of the Hallstatt period,...
...and with every step, you meet remainders of the imperial and royal monarchies.
Yet, if you are interested in modern art and culture, you will find plenty to occupy yourself with.
Art and culture of the present and past meet here with great style and taste.
The area has always been an inspirational place for many artists,...
...from Franz Lehàr, Gustav Mahler, Gustav Klimt, to Klaus Maria Brandauer.